all right a couple of waves of cold
fronts and we're going to get the
leftovers of whatever makes it through
the sierras and over into the desert and
southern nevada let's get up to uh
heavenly ski resort just wanted to show
you've got a live webcam up there this
is about 8 600 feet and they have been
getting some blowing snow through the
morning hours it doesn't look quite as
bad now but they are looking to measure
the snow levels or the snow amounts in
feet there by the time the storm is done
winter storm warnings for us central
california nevada excuse me into
southern nevada those will start at 4
a.m tomorrow morning all the way till 4
a.m wednesday we could see four to eight
inches above 5000 feet and maybe up to a
foot up at lea canyon wind advisories
for all of us tomorrow as well as we're
looking at 45 maybe 50 plus mile an hour
winds so upper 50s today still above 55
tomorrow rain likely mid morning
tomorrow all the way until 9 p.m or
maybe even midnight heather we need the
rain could see a quarter of an inch so
we'll keep our fingers crossed for good
rainfall tomorrow and then the rest of
the week sunny for the most part in low
50s with mornings near freezing